speaking of uh people that remind you a
neural syphilis you posted this um what
what i'm trying to get my transitions
yeah you're good the transitions baby
the transitions the transitions are
badass here on the tony michaels podcast
you will not find a transition that is
better doesn't this guy remind you of
like a neurosyphilis in human form
though i mean oh like if neurosyphilis
became a human form it basically might
be in if it just again morphed into a
body into an animate object it was like
boom greg log this is this is neural
civilization some of y'all been reading
the newspaper do you think we're crazy
nobody's forcing you to be here today
drag him out right now in jesus name
drag both of them out in jesus name get
out in jesus name you demon you do it
while i'm preaching i'll take this
microphone and bust you to mouth with
the name of god cause we ain't playing
your stupid democrat games and so father
we need to be released in a spirit of
giving we might need to give a little
bit so we can increase security around
here and look it ain't gonna get no
better it's gonna get worse people to
make up our mind who side their own in
this fight saying that i called last
week to take up arms against the
government if they heard that it's
because they're smoking crack or
apparently they didn't pay attention you
got hating communists to marry you'll
find out what an insurrection here
because we ain't playing your garbage we
ain't playing your mess so that wasn't
at all what i said they don't care what
you say they only care what it sounds
like you say so that they can make you
say what they want you to say so they
can eviscerate you and the bible says
that we'll take it by force everybody
mad because i said that in this day and
age you can't be a christian and vote
democrat which by the way you can't okay
so i still believe that because
everybody's like oh what we need to do
is take away their tax exempt stash i
got an attorney and i dissolved our
stinking
501c3 in this church because the
government ain't going to tell me what i
can and what i can't say so irs
we don't need your stupid tax exempt
status i renounce
501c3 communism in this church
and the irs and the fbi and everybody
we've been turned into can eat my dirty
socks on live tv i'm sick of all these
limp-wristed false prophet pastors
siding with the democrats no wonder
these penny wearing pastors closed their
church down during coven a bunch of
sissies let their wife run the show i
revoke our 501 c 3 status and i arrest
we don't give two flips what you think
about it we gonna take away his five on
one no yay we gave it up it's stupid so
you and all your compromising communism
501c3 can get out
when tyranny becomes law rebellion
becomes biblical i'm calling for
christians to stop being wimps is what
i'm calling for it's amazing what i'm
preaching on today by the way beware of
false prophets which come to you in
sheep's clothing but inwardly they're
ravening wolves i i was getting this
clip confused with another one that came
out i think tennessee tennessee holler
had the other one that i was thinking of
yeah yeah talking about the irs because
that was that was the popular one oh
yeah he's basically saying we are
political organizations we are not we
are not charitable organizations right
exactly he's making the case right for
why they should not have this tax-exempt
status right and they're all pissed off
because they're like listen i need
another g5 on the runway
so i can just fly it in unison with my
other one you know will you shut the
[ __ ] up for a minute quit saying the
quiet part out loud drag him out right
now in jesus name drag both of them drag
him out in jesus name
hey can you kill that guy but in jesus
name this is why greg locke is losing
his mind this is why people like kenneth
copeland and these other pastors are
abandoning this fool because as as much
as he projects that he knows the
skeletons in their closets what he's
saying in that last clip we were
watching they know the skeletons in his
closet oh yeah they know the skeleton oh
it's a two-way street that's right whole
whole way down and this whole i use god
my god is my excuse to do all my sins
like this is this is [ __ ] ridiculous
this is total full-on projection and
you're gonna see it with the irs thing
here what we need to do is take away
their tax exempt stash he's saying what
everyone is thinking here even even like
kenneth copeland and all his other
pastor buddies they're thinking the same
thing like yeah strip this guy of his
501 c3 and concentrate and focus on greg
lock don't focus over here and
definitely focus on greg locke now he
understands that even if he doesn't have
a tax-exempt status he still has to deal
with um what's that agency that um the
irs the irs is like we don't give a [ __ ]
if you're exempt or not right we just
need to know if you are and if we need
to collect taxes from your dumb ass the
other thing that he says is that 501 c3s
are communism so basically what greg
locke is saying is all the 501c3 he's
been doing all these years
all that's been communism yeah a lot of
projections yeah this whole thing is
wild i watched this uh sermon from
sunday you watched the whole thing no i
didn't watch it oh okay like holy [ __ ]
into about an hour because like the
first hour they're playing music and
doing all those stuff and he kind of
they're actually doing the god thing
it's like yeah yeah it's like a couple
before greg goes out on his tangent
right exactly and it's not just he
doesn't just go after uh kenneth
copeland in the situation he goes after
other people as well just kenneth
copeland is the like primary target that
is in his island is this he's like i got
a target on ken copeland whether it's
out of envy jealousy or he actually does
believe kenneth copeland is a demon and
oakland is a demon i will agree yeah i
agree with gregor listen last week
i believe it was we played a
a video of greg locke talking about how
he was gonna you know take the
government by force and democrats or
demons and democrats can't be christians
and all this nonsense on and on and on
it went now apparently over the weekend
uh some tick tockers got a hold of this
and they decided to mass report greg
locke to the irs about his 501 c3 i i'm
going to go on a limb here i don't think
he actually dissolved his 501 3c well i
mean if you're saying that greg lock is
a liar then i would definitely agree
everyone's like oh my god he's not
exempt anymore and i'm gonna say
[ __ ] i don't know if he dissolved it
he ha they were like you're not one
anymore or he's in the process of doing
it but but either way we're gonna we're
gonna look at this video because i find
it very interesting a couple different
things about griglock because if you go
out on the interwebs youtube especially
and you go to some of these right-wing
pastors who are uh anti-lgbtq
they they they [ __ ] say some hateful
ass [ __ ] i mean just hateful bigoted
[ __ ] they do but they're christians
black but they do not like great glock
they have turned on greg yeah yeah
because greg locke puts them at risk
here with some of the [ __ ] he says
because he really does borderline on
threats he really does uh put a 501c3 in
jeopardy and that's their entire
existence right like their entire
existence to spread their hatred and
bigotry is to do it tax-free right yeah
we do it tax-free we don't get taxed now
greg lock in this video you're going to
see how he denounces a 501c3 which is
kind of funny and i'll tell you why but
you tweeted jesus i think it's safe to
say manga hate preacher greg locke does
not like televangelist grifter kenneth
copeland which if anyone knows kenny
copeland out there you know he's a woo
he's a wack dude he's the one that was
member of the covet he was
what what's the video you gotta pick
yeah yeah i'll find the video
where he blows like spitting blowing it
away or some [ __ ] some weird ass [ __ ]
like stop spitting on me you kobe
spreader in this video that we're gonna
watch of greg lock here which is uh
i think a couple minutes long kenneth
copeland is a demon and he knows it is
what greg locke said so let's i'm
telling you there are more demons in
evangelical pulpits
than there are hookers in the red light
district of la right now they everywhere
we don't have a red light district here
in la i just want to preface that for
people we do not have one that i know of
at least see this is this is the [ __ ]
they do this is projection greg locke
has definitely 100
ordered had sex with and probably done
some
really really gross [ __ ] to prostitutes
sex work is work people we should not
demonize these people we should not make
these people unsafe and griglock is
making the these people who do this job
very unsafe and i'm sure he has done
some vile [ __ ] to people who are in that
field of work and greg locke definitely
has been in the quote unquote red light
district wherever the [ __ ] he thinks
that yeah and he has ordered prostitutes
and had sex with prostitutes this is
projection and nobody wants to expose
them and i get people they'll fight me i
can't believe you named that name i
can't believe you still gullible enough
to follow that fool if i got to run
around with pedophiles if i got to run
around with money grubbing nonsense i
ain't messing with him um more
projection yeah i mean what the [ __ ]
does this have to do with preaching a
sermon from the bible i don't know he
went on a comp he went on a tangent
because the the the sermon it was given
it was like do not follow false prophets
and then he went to this whole thing
about he's like listen i'm going to say
some stuff that you don't like and i'm
okay with losing friends but what i will
tell you kenneth copeland is a grifter
he's a demon he's a dead he's a false
prophet he goes
yeah well he doesn't actually say
grifter in here i just said grifter
because that's what he is right well he
calls him false prophet he calls him a
demon and then he goes into the whole
masonic demonic cult thing it's a whole
it's it's
so so so you cut this down right yeah
you went in and you you cut this clip
down to what what we have here yeah this
is like how long was this diatribe that
he uh i want to say that the actual
rant he went on was like maybe 15 to 20
minutes so this is the juicy stuff this
is the juicy stuff there's other people
he mentions in there like just like a
couple things where he's like don't be
surprised if you see this person get
arrested and i was like i don't know if
anyone's gonna really know who these
people are so i just focused on kenneth
copeland and boy did he have a lot to
say about kenneth copeland well let's
get to it so i'm gonna hurt some of you
feelings right now i'm gonna hurt a lot
of my friends feelings right now kenneth
copeland is a heretic you hear me
kenneth copeland is the number one
christian heretic in america
he hates him some [ __ ] kenneth
copeland yeah yeah i he [ __ ] he he
has turned on kenneth copeland here my
guess is it's because kenneth copeland
definitely won't uh throw down any kind
of funds to probably maybe maybe they
don't go to the same you know sex orgy
parties i don't i you know those cocaine
sex orgies are kind of exclusive i hear
so you may have to have an invitation
and greg locke has lost his i guess
remember this guy is is doing his sermon
in tennessee right it's in tennessee i
don't know usually he's in a circus tent
like well he really yeah he's in a
circus tent and this is the circus folks
that you're watching here literally for
the show baby welcome to the clown
paying none of my bills and i wouldn't
take none of his blood money no how
false prophets are false prophets quit
sending the money and buying their books
kenneth copeland is a demon and he knows
it i don't care how much money he's got
he's got a lot and he got it off of
naive christians that ought to tie it to
their local church and quit sending the
money i'm just letting it settle in on
you for it i know i got some friends
right now they're like
who's committing pastoral suicide oh
it's not just friends that are like that
greg it's not just your friends like
everyone everybody watching this is like
he's over here like fanning he's like
sorry i just put out a big ass fart of
pastoral scenes oh my god this this
[ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy whoosh oh
no i'm not i wouldn't preach for him if
he begged me tomorrow on his knees you
know why kenneth copeland won't sue me
because he knows i got the receipts he's
a false prophet kenny copeland should be
under the jail you would be shocked if
you knew what's going on behind closed
doors in these pastors offices wait a
second if this guy knows all this stuff
isn't he culpable into knowing all this
stuff i mean really he says
i don't doubt that there's a lot of [ __ ]
right no for sure for sure i don't know
how he knows if somebody told him he was
the cuck in the corner or he was
watching through a little peephole right
inside of uh inside of a painting you
know like a [ __ ] scooby-doo villain
right but if he knows these things then
he is a witness or he's complicit in a
crime that was committed in these
offices of different pastors what the
[ __ ] does that mean i mean really this
has the stench of cocaine sex orgies
madison
cousins stuff oh this is right yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah this definitely has
cousin humping written all over and it
is you know it is greg locke and it is
kenneth copeland so you know i don't
know if they're related but maybe that
hey i don't know because the bible says
be what a false prophet so apparently
they're around the only thing they get
me on being a false prophet is i call
out democrats and preach against demons
well if that makes me a false prophet
then la da
da da da really honestly this is a
circus i want to see more juggling
really honestly i mean if he brought out
clowns to juggle like bowling pins or
something right i mean
look i would watch every week greg if
you had the clowns come out and do some
juggling and [ __ ] maybe like like the
the fire breathers oh yeah yeah
that might be a little too demonic you
know you know it's like ooh we got
satan's satan's cult up here you know
well well he's going to talk about
satan's cult here in just a second
listen to this i dare kenneth copeland
to take me to court and sue me for what
i'm about to say he is a 33rd degree
mason why why would kenneth copeland
take him to court because he's a mason
what does that have to do with it that
might be what he's about to say in a
moment oh let's see he is in the masonic
satanic cult
there you go
there you go oh my god what is this [ __ ]
going to be a spectator at the great
white throne judgment when god looks at
kenneth copeland and says depart from me
ye that work iniquity you going to hell
for all of eternity cause you a lying
sorry low down good for nothing sack of
false prophecy we'll wait till we get
all the uh the cards on the table and
we'll just have us a big old national
press conference and we'll just call
them all what they are and now back to
the sermon yeah